(CROWD CHEERS)
There's not enough noise!
♪ (HIP HOP MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
SPEAKER: I remember
the first time seeing his name
up there with Drake,
Juice, Taylor Swift,
in that top five in the world.
Juice wasn't trying to be that.
Juice just became that,
just making good music.
JUICE WRLD: When you're a fan
of this shit, you look at it
from a certain perspective.
But when you in it, you
see it for what it really is.
I'm still happy
I can change the world,
but it's not
what it looked like.
♪ ("GREAT GREAT"
BY NICK JORDAN PLAYS) ♪
SPEAKER 2: He was so good
at articulating his feelings,
we ain't realize
that's the way he feeling,
'cause it turned into
so much beautiful art.
It was hard to separate the two.
JUICE WRLD: You know,
you tell whoever that
you feel like you got anxiety,
you feel like
you got depression,
they gonna look at you
like you crazy.
That's not how it should be.
That's how it is,
and that needs to change.
And hopefully,
I'm one of those people
that can bring that change.
Sometimes this shit
gets overwhelming,
but this is what I asked for.
I say certain things
so I can have conversations
with my friends.
If people getting it
and it relates to their life,
then I'd love for them
to get that shit.
BENNY BLANCO:
Juice was a therapist
for millions of kids,
a voice of that generation.
JUICE WRLD: I wanna say
thank you and I love you
to all my supporters out there.
This is your world.
You can do
whatever you wanna do.
♪ (MUSIC BUILDS) ♪
♪ (HIP HOP MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪